involves a team that did not play
tonight and that's the Golden State
Warriors in the wake of last night's
Skirmish with the Minnesota Timberwolves
the league handed down a five game
suspension on Draymond Green for his
choke hold headlock whatever you want to
call it on Rudy goar they also issued
$25,000 fines for Klay Thompson J
McDaniels and goar and you see the the
history that the rrap sheet if you will
that green has put together in the NBA I
can't believe he's only been suspended
nine games it seems like more over the
years you see the ejections and the fine
money is outrageous that is money that
he's left on the table over the course
of his NBA career that's a really nice
house it's you think so that's a really
nice house in a lot of places it's
several really
nice lot of houses that's a really nice
house depends on where you live I guess
but and I think from my standpoint um
the league got it right I mean they even
could have been higher and I think you
know I've been knowing Draymond forever
but I don't think it was just because of
what happened in that instance and I
know they won't say that but I think
it's been a combination of sometimes
they will say that sometimes they will
say if you get a track record it's going
to affect you're not going to get the
benefit of the doubt but I think
Draymond is standing on that um and I
also do think that this was kind of a
buildup of the last two or three games
you saw um the scuffle with Donovan
Mitchell you see the intention with
Anthony Edwards that's draymond's emo in
terms of he's tough he's gonna you know
he's going to be that protector and and
that player on the team I think where
the Warriors need him is on the court M
and so he has to do all that while
staying on the court um but I also am
wondering the fine for clay you think
clay Klay Thompson should have been
should have been fined like in a regular
situation where that doesn't escalate
escalate if it doesn't escalate he's
probably not F does he get Fin and I
guess that's my thing if we're talking
about past you know offenses or past
occurrences like to me I feel like has
had a clean sleep I think he doesn't if
that if that if the choke doesn't happen
but why after after the fact why get
fined for something that happen call the
Le I'm just yeah I'm just I also think
this man is that does not obviously
excuse Draymond for what he did Rudy
should never grab the opposing team
player and I think that's you know you
shouldn't get choked for it but you got
to grab your players but when you start
grabbing even if peacemaking even
peacemaking I you always there Unwritten
rules you I'm going to grab met we're
teammates okay but let's not let's not
skip over the fact that like Rudy and
Draymond have had something in the past
so there is something with that but if I
see Rudy grabbing clay that gives me to
say Let Me Go protect my guy listen I'm
all for that because I because if Rudy
was grabbing Daniels he's not going to
go grab him and I completely agree with
you and in this case I think it's the
manner of grab think it was the manner
in the length of time grab but he
couldn't grab him if he was grabbing he
wouldn't grab him then I'm not
disagreeing with you probably not I'm
not disagreeing with you I think it was
the length of the grab and the fact that
he didn't let
go